das rohmet Klinikum im bayerischen
Rosenheim über 2.000 kubit-patienten
wurden hier bisher behandelt 400 davon
auf der Intensivstation
versorgt werden sie von Ärzten wie Karl
Ziegler und seinem Team auch heute
werden sie hier fast ohne Pause
durcharbeiten und so geht es schon seit
Monaten
man wird langsam müde was einen halt
besonders belastet ist dass es einfach
vermeidbar gewesen wäre mittlerweile
hätte man
die Chance gehabt durch Impfung diese
vierte Welle zu verhindern und das ist
nicht geschehen und das macht uns
natürlich traurig
sechs schwerkranke Patienten sind
derzeit auf der covid-intensivstation
Menschen zwischen 8 und 30 und 60 Jahren
fast alle sind sie ungeimpft
knapp 50 Patienten davon hatten zwei
vollständigen Impfschutz das heißt wir
haben viele viele Patienten mittleren
Alters ohne relevante Vorerkrankungen
die trotzdem
intensivpflichtig werden wie dieser
junge Mann vorher kerngesund jetzt
kämpft er um sein Leben betreut wird der
von intensivpflegekraft Cornelia weiß
Stöckl seit 25 Jahren ist sie im Dienst
im Vergleich zu den ersten Wellen der
Pandemie habe sich aktuell vieles
verändert es sei noch anstrengender
geworden sagt sie
Leute werden immer jünger definitiv und
dann ist halt dass man damit zu kämpfen
hat das sehr sehr viel ungeimpfte
Patienten da sind
mit sich dem auseinanderzusetzen ist
äußerst schwierig psychisch und auch
physisch am Tag betreut Cornelia weiß
Stöckl zwei Patienten in der
Nachtschicht 3 mit im Team
Physiotherapeut Michael furos die vielen
ungeimpften auf Station es beschäftigt
auch den 36-Jährigen
klar mache ich mir in meiner Pause
daheim einen Kopf drüber bin auch wütend
vor allem auf diejenigen die die Impfung
einfach aus zeitlichen Gründen sage ich
mal vor sich herschieben aus Faulheit
Bequemlichkeit das versuche ich aber
natürlich hier oben auf der Station
sobald ich hier reingehe einfach
auszublenden acht
covid-intensivpatienten können auf
Station gleichzeitig behandelt werden es
sei nicht die Arbeit der Stress der
belaste für Oberarzt Ziegler manchmal
fühle es sich auch einfach alleine
gelassen was ich schon verstehe ist dass
mittlerweile keiner mehr Interesse daran
hat sich mit dem Thema zu befassen nach
eineinhalb Jahren wir haben da auch
keine kein Interesse dran an dem Thema
uns betrifft es aber leider tagtäglich
deswegen können wir nicht aus nicht aus
können im Gegenteil alle Intensivplätze
sind meist belegt und Entspannung ist
keine in Sicht nicht in Rosenheim seit
Monaten ist die Inzidenz in der Stadt
und im Landkreis hoch viel zu hoch und
die Menschen sind zunehmend genervt man
ist halt einfach eingeschränkt muss
überall entweder Impfausweis oder
genesenen vorzeigen
das ist einfach nicht
entspannt
einfach weil man tut ja viel dafür Magie
der immer testen oder impfen oder bleibt
zu Hause geht nicht auf Partys und die
Belohnung ist hohe inzidenzzahlen wo man
sich dann erwarten herkommen die denke
es kommt durch den Urlaub die Menschen
wo eben im Urlaub in Kroatien waren oder
Türkei was sind die Gründe für die hohen
Inzidenzen eine Frage die viele in der
63.000 Einwohner Stadt umtreibt
Spurensuche die erste Anlaufstelle das
Impfzentrum Rosenheim Hans Maierl ist
der Koordinator die bundesweit gibt es
auch hier kaum noch impfige und dabei
habe man alles unternommen um den
Impfstoff an die Menschen zu bringen
wir sind zu Fußballspielen gefahren wir
waren vor Einkaufszentren sogar bei
unserem beliebten Chiemsee war mir am
Hafengelände und haben dort Menschen
geimpft die einfach nur spontan vor Ort
waren
und doch es habe zu wenig gebracht die
impfzahlen sind immer noch viel zu
niedrig weniger als 60% der Rosenheimer
sind zum zweiten Mal geimpft Markus
Peschl hat sich durchgerungen zu seiner
ersten Impfung gegen Corona und das habe
ihn Überwindung gekostet denn aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen sagt der
Familienvater würde er sich nicht impfen
lassen warum dann zu groß geworden jetzt
weil ab 11 Oktober wenn dann die Tests
ja kostenpflichtig auch in beruflichen
Bereich wenn man in Quarantäne muss der
dann und umkämpft ist dass man eventuell
schon keinen Lohnfortzahlung schon
bekommt also der Hauptaspekt ist der
finanzielle auf jeden Fall
eine Viertelstunde später Markus Peschl
wird geimpft erleichtert
im Grunde ja wenigstens meine Freiheiten
kommen würde Unsicherheit wie bei Markus
Peschl sie sei kein Einzelfall so
Impfarzt Michael riffelmacher ja es ist
bei einigen nach wie vor noch eine ganz
große Unsicherheit und Verunsicherung zu
spüren und das ganze hat natürlich auch
irgendwo eine eine Plattform gefunden im
Bereich der sozialen Medien wie auch
eine Angst oder eine Zurückhaltung
transportieren und die bemerke er auch
häufig bei Menschen aus anderen
Kulturkreisen
die was was diesen medizinischen Bereich
angeht einfach diese Offenheit
vielleicht noch nicht haben ich mag das
nicht wert ich mag das auch nicht
beurteilen ich denke mal es ist an uns
da noch etwas mehr Aufklärungsarbeit zu
leisten
in Rosenheim liegt der Ausländeranteil
bei etwas mehr als
22%. die Bevölkerungsstruktur sei
mitverantwortlich für die hohen
Inzidenzen ist aus dem Rathaus zu hören
seit Mai 2020 ist Andreas märz statt
Oberhaupt das pandemiegeschehen
beunruhigt auch ihn die kobit-fälle die
wir hatten ohne den Datenschutz jetzt
dort zu verletzen wann überwiegend oder
praktisch nur reiserückkehrer aus
Südosteuropa auch Landsleute aus den aus
dem ehemaligen jugoslawischen Staaten
und insofern
habe ich da kein Problem dass auch offen
anzusprechen und die gelte es zu
erreichen so der Oberbürgermeister und
von der Impfung gegen kovit zu
überzeugen wir haben dann mit einer in
einer Briefaktion in der Landessprache
die Menschen noch mal an die Menschen
noch mal appelliert sich impfen zu
lassen weil wir festgestellt haben dass
praktisch nur ungeimpfte
coronafälle im Klinikum landen auch auf
die Intensivstationen
impfen oder nicht in der Stadt sind die
Meinungen dazu geteilt bin ich
eigentlich dafür weil ich möchte
irgendwann mein normales Leben wieder
zurück ohne Masken feiern gehe
vorgefreunde treffen
ohne Einschränkungen die Impfquote
können natürlich höher sein das ist ganz
klar da muss man einfach
Überzeugungsarbeit leisten wo immer es
geht die Impfquote muss halt steigen
nein
weil ich dem Impfstoff Nichtraucher
an mich weil du wirst verrückt mit dem
ganzen
zurück in das rohmet-klinikum auf der
Intensivstation Lagern Oberarzt Karl
Ziegler und das Pflegeteam einen
schwerkranken kovit-patienten um auch er
ist ungeimpft es ist Schwerstarbeit doch
es sei nicht nur die Anstrengung die auf
Dauer mürbe mache sagt Franziska die
22-Jährige Pflegekraft
so jede kleinste Bewegung wirkt sich auf
dem Körper aus wie Dauerlauf es ist sehr
heiß und wenn man dann leider Gottes
noch die Patienten hat die sich äußern
dass das Corona nicht gäbe obwohl sie
hier liegen und viele andere hier liegen
dann kostet es schon ganz viel
Überwindung
corona-leugner und im Verweigerer das
Verhalten mancher Menschen
ärgere ihn zunehmend zu der
Geschäftsführer der Klinik denn es gehe
zu Lasten seines Teams das längst schon
an der Belastungsgrenze ist
das löst natürlich bei den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen verständlicherweise das
Gefühl auf warum soll ich mich
eigentlich jeden Tag
schützen warum soll ich mich eigentlich
jeden Tag persönlich in Gefahr bringen
auch meine Angehörigen meine Familie in
Gefahr bringen für Menschen die schlicht
und einfach sich nicht an Spielregeln
halten auf der Intensivstation können
wir mit einer Patientin sprechen sie
möchte nicht zu erkennen sein nach Tagen
ist sie endlich über den Berg
es muss wirklich ganz schlimm um mich
gestanden haben also das überlegt wurde
ob man mich ins künstliche Koma legt
künstliche Beatmung intubieren alles
mögliche es muss sehr kritisch gewesen
sein
auch sie hatte sich nicht impfen lassen
weil ich dem Impfstoff noch nicht
vertraue aber ich würde diese
Entscheidung obwohl ich jetzt hier schon
seit über einer Woche liege da hat sich
an meiner Meinung nichts geändert ich
würde mich nach wie vor nicht impfen
lassen ob denn ihr Mann und ihre Familie
geimpft sind nein kein Mensch auch mein
86-jähriger Vater nicht
Momente wie diese sind es die es dem
Team schwer machen ruhig zu bleiben sich
auf ihre Arbeit zu konzentrieren
es habe auch schon Angriffe von
impfkritikern gegeben sagt Oberarzt Karl
Ziegler verbale vereinzelt auch
körperliche gibt es immer wieder es ist
natürlich extrem ermüdend weil das mal
ist natürlich vollkommen überflüssig
dann auch noch seine Zeit mit so einem
Unsinn zu verbringen wenn man ohnehin
schon genug zu tun hat dann sind dann
gelegentlich
relativ eindeutige Ansagen erforderlich
diese Situation sei den Medizinern und
Pflegekräften nicht mehr zuzumuten zu
der Geschäftsführer der Klinik er
fordert klare Botschaften von Seiten der
Politik ich glaube wir sind an einem
Punkt angekommen wo wir eine Impfpflicht
brauchen weil zu viel auf dem Spiel
steht und weil die Situation für meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unerträglich
ist
und manche im Team auch krank macht wie
etwa intensivpflegekraft Cornelia weiß
Stöckl trotz zweimaliger Impfung steckte
sie sich bei einem Patienten mit kovit
an doch aufhören und für sie nicht in
Frage man geht trotzdem hierher man
möchte empathisch sein und ist es auch
weil es ist unser Beruf und man macht
das nur wie lange noch eine Frage die
Stationsleiter Martin Reum umtreibt seit
knapp 20 Jahren arbeitet er hier es ist
eigentlich so dass die Leute einfach
jetzt nur noch durchhalten wir müssen
irgendwie was an der Situation ändern
weil wir können nicht Welle 5 6 7 8 9
halten wir nicht aus
vor der Intensivstation wartet ein neuer
covid-patient auch er ist nicht geimpft
doch wieder werden sie alles tun um dem
schwerkranken zu helfen zu Oberarzt
Ziegler denn das sei schließlich ihr Job